okay welcome back everybody so it's my
pleasure to
to introduce jeff calder who's going to
do
the last talk of today it's going to be
a
traditional whiteboard talk and he's
going to talk about convergence rates
for the leap sheets learning thank you
very much okay yeah so
uh thank you very much for the
invitation to to talk so i haven't given
you know a talk with a chalkboard or a
whiteboard like a year and a half so i
thought it would be a good opportunity
to do this um
now so
i i'm just going to talk about some
very recent work
um which is joint with uh
[Music]
uh
leon bungert and
uh tim royce who are both um
attendees here at the workshop and it's
we should have a preprint very very soon
um
on this idea and so
uh just to get into things um we will
have a graph which will be the central
object of
study like in other talks um
this week and so that we have uh
vertices
we'll call them omega n
so x1 through xn
which are a subset of a domain
omega which is a subset of
euclidean space
and we have edge weights
so these are w i j between two nodes x i
and x j
and this is
eta of
x i minus x j
divided by a length scale h okay um so
we connect uh points that are nearby in
space with with an edge weight and so
the picture for
eta is that it starts off large at say
one and then decays to zero
before you get to
say 1
here
so h is the graph bandwidth
and so attached to these to this graph
you also have labeled data
okay which is a function g
on
a subset i'll call it script o n
into just the real numbers for now but
you can extend these things to
vector valued labels
so this is some subset of the vertices
in the graph
and the task uh
we'll talk about is this thing called
graph based semi-supervised learning
which is to extend
the labels from g
or from o n
to the rest of the graph so from the
constraint sets to the rest of the graph
so there are lots of
techniques for doing this
a lot of them have
either variational or pde
formulations on on graphs so one thing
you can do is to look at
the minimum of some
regularization energy
e
over functions on the graph
um
subject to
the labels agreeing on
the constraint set
um
and there are lots of different
variations of this
instead of this hard constraint i could
add
a soft
label fidelity as well so there are lots
of
techniques like this
one such example is p laplacian
regularization
p
p laplace learning corresponds to
the energy e p of u
is the sum
w i j
u x i
minus u x j to the p
and i'll put a power p on here as well
um
so the idea here at least is that i want
to make sure that my label function is
as smooth as possible where i measure
smoothness by this energy and i want the
labels to agree at these labeled notes
and now there's been you know quite a
bit of work on these kinds of models
when you have very few
labeled examples so the set script o n
is very small
the sort of common case of taking p is
equal to 2
is quite ill-posed
meaning that
p is p is equal to 2 is ill opposed
when the size of
the constraint set is very small
and the reason sort of is because you
know here
you would be looking at harmonic
functions with you know boundary
conditions that
on a set a very small measure or a set
that has too small measure to have any
positive capacity and so you can't
attain label
conditions so you get these sort of very
spiky
solutions where the
solution is trying to attain the labels
but also trying to be constant on the
graph and you can get very very poor
results here and so it's been suggested
you know
and studied by myself and others
the problem of taking much larger values
of p to enforce
um sort of stronger regularity on these
functions and one thing you can do is
you can take the limit
limit as p goes to infinity
and that's the study of this talk this
is what we call lipschitz learning
so in that case the energy you get
essentially e infinity
the max of w i j
the essentially some kind of lipschitz
constant for
for the function
and now this is what you get if you take
the power p on the weight if you don't
take the power p on the weight then
actually the weights disappear and it's
just it's an unweighted graph
essentially okay so this gives you a
more general
setting if you take the power p on these
weights
um and so actually the solution to this
problem minimizing this subject to
the label agreement here is not a well
posed problem there are infinitely many
solutions
a really simple example
is here's a very simple graph so i'm
going to put
a bunch of nodes back to back i think i
need five of them
and the red numbers will be the label
constraints
so i'm going to put a 0 here and a 2
here
sorry
a 2 here
and two over here as well so these are
the labeled
labels guys
and i want to then assign labels here
and here now this is the graph structure
so i can have edges here here here here
they all have edge weights of one let's
say
so i'm just minimizing the difference in
the labels across these edges
so here i have to put a one
right this gives me the smallest ellipse
it's constant
that's the solution here
um but over here you know maybe i want
it to be two to be constant right but
anything between one and three will give
me the same lipschitz constant of one
right here
so the value i put here could be
anything between one
and three and i'm still i'm still
minimizing the objective but you want to
put the value two here okay
um and to characterize that
solution um there are several ways to do
it so in the machine learning literature
people look at these things called lex
minimizers
which essentially what you do is you
take the gradient which in the graph
setting the gradient's just a discrete
object
it's all of the differences across edges
and for any two solutions you can look
at the lexographical ordering on
gradients and you can take
the minimizer with the which is smallest
in the lexicographical ordering and
that's that's one way to do it an
equivalent way which has been used in
analysis for some time
is this thing called absolutely minimal
lipschitz extension which basically says
that instead of minimizing the worst
case which is constant over the whole
graph i also ask that among all
minimizers
i select the one that cannot be locally
improved on any subset of the graph
right so
let's see
both of these notions are actually
equivalent
and both of them give you an euler
lagrange equation on the graph that's
nice to write down
so both
amle
and lex minimizers
solve the following graph infinity
laplace equations i'll write it as l h
infinity of u
zero
on the graph
minus the constraint set
subject to u is equal to g
on the constraint set okay
where this l infinity h is the infinity
graph laplacian
which is max
plus min
okay over j
of w i j
u x j minus u x r
um how can you see this there are
several ways but probably the easiest
is to take the gradient of this set it
equal to zero you get the p laplacian on
the graph and then send p to infinity
formally at least
and the same way you get the max here
for the energy if you send p to infinity
in the gradient of this and split the
positive negative terms apart
you get exactly this over here
and now so the question is you know what
do you get
in this uh you know discrete to
continuum limits that we've talked about
a lot in this workshop so if i take the
the large
sample size so we're interested in
looking at the
uh continuum
n goes to infinity and h goes to zero
limit of this equation on the graph to
understand the well you know why this
gives you uh you know a good method for
propagating labels at let's say very low
label rates so this has been studied in
several previous papers by myself and by
other people we're giving some new
insights
on the convergence rates for this
problem
so just to give an idea now i'm gonna
see how
quickly i'm going here
now if you haven't seen these kind of
problems before you might not
see right away what the continuum pde
should look like
but it's not hard to see what one should
get
so if you take remember that we had
these weights i just erased this but we
had
the weights our geometric weights
um and let's
just consider the case where ada is the
characteristic function of
the unit interval
or
simplicity here then if you look at the
max
of u of y
over y that are in
a ball of radius h
okay so this is what you get here if the
weights are just one you're looking at
the max and the min
of a function at nearby points and say
we pass from discrete to non-local so
it's not a max over the point cloud but
it's a max
over a ball like this now and what you
should get is that this should be
roughly
u of x plus
h
in the direction of the gradient
and of course if you take the min you
should get the same thing but with a
minus sign here
so if i write down the graph infinity
laplacian
at x i
um
you know what i should get
is
uh
a term like this
u
let's just write x instead of x i
plus h grad u over norm graph u
i should get that plus a term like x
minus h
like this
and then minus 2
u of x
all right so i'm not optimizing over the
x i the x i the
u of x i is just fixed and i have two of
them from the max
so this looks essentially
like
a second derivative
estimation right so for the second
derivative in the direction
of the gradient so this should give you
approximately h squared
times grad u over
norm grad u
has cn of u
grad u over norm grad u
and this thing is what we call the
infinity laplacian
view so it's the second derivative of u
in the direction of the gradient
and that's the equation that you should
get
in the continuum limit um
of this guy here
of course you know this isn't a very
simple setting where the weights are the
characteristic function of an interval
but you can extend
these arguments to more general settings
okay
um so to write down the continuum
problem
um and feel free to ask you know
questions throughout the talk whenever
whenever you feel like it
you should have
infinity laplacian of u is equal to 0
on the domain omega so to draw a picture
you know
i have this domain
omega and i have these points that are
in my graph
but i also have special points that are
labeled which are the red points let's
say
okay that's um
the constraint set and the setting will
be that this is sort of a finite
collection of points
that are converging to a finite
collection of points script o in the
continuum
and so i'll have the dirshay condition
on this set
o let's say so we'll have to have in
some sense that o n converges to o
and what you should get is the natural
uh
neumann condition which is the natural
variational boundary condition on
topological boundary of omega so this
should be our continuum problem
um
but there are actually several ways to
equivalently
equivalently interpret this problem
um
yeah
um
it's a good question so you can see it
through
a limit of say pilopas equations p goes
to infinity
so if you were to say
look at the dirichlet problem
you know minimize
integral of grad u squared
right over a domain without boundary
conditions you would get the neumann
condition it's a natural variational
condition
you would get the same thing if this is
a power p for finite p as well
and so if you send p to infinity you
would expect to get neumann condition as
well
actually this it's a little difficult to
establish well opposingness in general
for here so the best that we can figure
out is that if omega's convex you can
get well-posedness for this equation
but what i talked about with the
amle the absolutely minimal lipschitz
extension this stuff carries over to
non-convex domains and so on so there's
the equivalent amle
interpretation of the continuum problem
which is you know the same as what's on
the graph i didn't write it for the
graph so let's write it for the
continuum
it says that
essentially
uh for every set v
compactly contained in the closure of
omega
we have that the lip shit's constant
of
u
on v is the same as the lipschitz
constant restricted to the boundary
so it's the essentially
the optimal extension on any sub-domain
as well you have to interpret for the
neumann condition you have to interpret
the boundary as the relative boundary in
the induced apology on on the closure so
it doesn't include the boundary of omega
in here this is some small technical
points
and there's a third thing called
comparison with cones
which i'll won't write down now
but if i have time to write down a very
short
idea of a proof you will see this thing
show up
and these are actually three equivalent
ways of looking at the continuum problem
if omega is convex
whereas amle comparison with cones are
equivalent and more general in the
non-convex setting as well and let's
let's say you know we're not sure that
we can't
establish well-postedness here for
non-convex domains but this seems
challenging and it seems to be open as
far as we are aware in the pde
literature
okay so now what can you say about the
continuum limits
here so we have our continuum model we
have the discrete model
so i'll give you an uh older result
um so this is just sort of an informal
theorem statement
um this is from the thesis of uh charlie
smart and
in 2010
it's in a more special setting so it's
that
omega is a grid
in
dimension two
spacing h
eta is the characteristic function of
the unit um interval
and this setting so he proved that u n
minus u
is less than a constant
third root
of delta n over h squared i'll say what
these things are shortly
for
this is for h much less than delta to
the
five so delta n is the resolution of the
point cloud okay
so essentially
i'll write it as the hazdorf distance of
omega n to omega
plus we'll also have an
uh
term to control the convergence of the
constraint set
so basically how far do i have to move
uh points in omega to find the closest
point in omega n
now so this kind of results okay it's
it's specialized in various ways but
it's not so important that it's a grid
or that you're in dimension two for the
techniques they go through
for a graph in more generality but as
far as we can see
the choice of eta actually is a little
bit important for these
techniques
and then there's a theorem in the paper
that i wrote
in 2019
which
operates in the full graph setting with
general kernels but worked on
the flat torus
to get rid of this boundary condition
and sorry yeah
u n is the solution of
this equation thank you
solution of this equation up here thanks
okay so it's the solution of the
discrete graph problem with end points
and with a length scale h
the
absolute difference over the graph
yeah
so if you restrict restrict the function
u
continuum problem to the graph and look
at the absolute difference take the max
over the graph
great yeah
uh
sorry it's it's uh sorry omega n
omega n is a grid of spacing h sorry
thank you please please please uh you
know ask questions like this this is
very good
oh so actually i forgot to mention as
well so in smarts in smart's work
it's not really the neumann problem so
here
his constraint set is a tube around the
boundary so it's really the dirichlet
problem
in this in this setting and it can be
arbitrary boundary values okay so this
is quite an informal result because it's
not in the same setting that i that i'm
talking about but the idea is you know
we use a lot of ideas from this from
this work
on on this set
this this is not so important so in our
in our work is just a finite collection
of points because the solutions are
ellipses in this case
the the geometry
or conditions on the constraints that
are not so important
yeah
so if you if you look at the sequence of
minimizers for the p1000 energy yeah
does that select the amle of the
continuum of minimizers that you've got
it it it does in the
convex setting
i i would suspect it does in general i'm
not sure if we have a proof of that yeah
thank you
okay so the the other result
to say so so this is in a paper i wrote
recently
um somewhat recently is uh there is no
convergence rate but the
the condition on h is better so u n
converge this to u
for h much bigger than delta n to the
two thirds
so implicit in this kind of rate is that
h is much bigger than
square root of delta and
or else the rate becomes vacuous
essentially
um and when you're working with you know
graph based learning you actually want
to work at length scales h the h is the
graph bandwidth you want to work with
length scales h that are very close to
delta n okay so essentially the graph is
connected
for h bigger than a constant times
this delta n
and in practice you usually work pretty
close to this graph connectivity
threshold so you have very very sparse
graphs
and the sort of the existing theory for
convergence rates is is lacking in this
regard because you have these very large
length scale restrictions on h which are
not something you would see in practice
ever and so the so the motivation for
this work is to see
if you can push these convergence rates
down to the graph connectivity threshold
very very small values of h
there's a work in this direction by
bungert and royth
where they proved gamma convergence
or the
discrete problems to continuum
um when
we're just above the graph connectivity
threshold and this so this is a recent
paper in 2020.
it's sort of somewhat
tangential to this discussion because
the gamma convergence doesn't detect
absolutely minimal electricity's
extensions and so uh you you you can't
as far as we can see you can't directly
get from this
that you have convergence of absolute
minimizers
so let me write down our result
so this is our theorem
okay so
our rate u n minus u is now the fourth
root
but what you see here is just delta n
over h
and this is for
and much less than h less than
delta n to the five 9.
and we do have a rate in the larger i
mean this is what we're sort of
interested in this is very very small
length scales but we do have a rate in
the
larger length scale regime
and it's just h to the one-fifth
so when you contrast it with the rate
from uh
smart's work the difference is we've
improved the denominator to h instead of
h squared but you lose this extra root
so from the cube root to the to the
fourth root here
but you can see in the rate all you need
is delta n much smaller than h
in order to get a non-vacuous rate
yeah so so just decreasing upper
semicontinuous
compactly supported yeah
okay so i hope to tell you a little bit
about
the proof of this
um and i think the the the ideas are
quite general right and so there are
more problems than just lipschitz
learning where you can't
get to these very small length skills
and we'd like to address these problems
and even though this is these ideas are
kind of
in some sense special to the infinity
laplacian
the main idea i think will apply to
other problems just with sort of
completely different ingredients
and so the idea is that you
if you look at this infinity laplacian
you
you know in these discrete to continuum
problems you always pass through a
non-local problem and you've seen this
in other talks in this workshop so far
and usually you pass to a non-local
operator that has the same bandwidth and
you're just sort of replacing sums by
integrals or so on so here you would
replace the max over the point cloud
with the max over the domain
instead we're going to pass to
a non-local operator
on
a much larger length scale
um where epsilon's much bigger than h
and this will be essentially some
homogenized operator where the weights
will now appear in just a constant up
front and not inside the operator itself
and so this operator is easy to write
down it's it's in lots of other works as
well
so this operator is
the infinity laplacian the sort of
non-local version of it which is
max plus min
this is over a ball
so both are over the ball of radius
epsilon around x
of u
minus two u of x i write b sub omega
because
this is a small thing that
there isn't time to explain in this talk
too much but we have to use geodesic
balls
so we measure the distance between
points by the shortest path in
non-convex sets okay
so most things distances and balls are
all geodesic balls
so this is our non-local operator you
don't see the weights in the graph
anywhere in here because they've been
homogenized into this constant
and so 8 is the only place where the
kernel shows up
and where can i write it
so beta is
our sigma beta
is the max of t
eta t
this is the only place that you see
the kernel showing up here and so this
idea of passing to a non-local operator
on a larger length scale i think is is a
general idea that could work for other
problems like
spectral convergence
if i have time i'll talk about ideas for
that
at the end but of course the ingredients
will be much different than in this talk
and so the idea is when you pass to this
larger length scale your length scale
restrictions now involve epsilon instead
of h you can work with a very very small
h on the graph and a much larger length
scale epsilon
okay
so the exact form of you know what does
what does this mean here is what i would
call discrete to non-local
and so what we prove
is
well first we have to have a way to
interpolate the function from the
graph to the domain
and because this is the infinity
laplacian there's a there's a very
special way to do this
so the function u n
on the graph
um i extend it to the continuum
i'll call it u n epsilon by taking the
max
of u over balls
okay i'll have to do the inversion of
this as well okay so this is a way to
extend
u n
from the point cloud to the to the
domain
and the result for discrete to continuum
is that if
i have a sub solution
on the graph
right so so minus laplacian of un is
less than or equal to zero of course
it's equal to zero if it's the solution
but
you need just the sub solution condition
then
minus
non-local operator
applied to this
extension is
close to zero okay approximately zero so
you get delta n over h epsilon
plus
um
h
over epsilon squared
and in some sense this term here you
should kind of think it was playing the
same role as
as this term in smart's rate but we've
decoupled the h and epsilon so one of
the h's became became epsilon
so you have this discrete to non-local
so you take the discrete function extend
to a non-local one that approximately
solves
the non-local operator and then you have
also a local to non-local
oftentimes you sort of always pass to
the to the local problem and do
everything here in this setting we sort
of meet in the middle so we take the
discrete to non-local but we also take
um
local to non-local everything meets in
this non-local problem okay and we do
the um the bulk of the argument here
so here we're going to take the
continuum thing
and do the same kind of
the same kind of
perturbation so u epsilon is the max
over balls
sorry
and u sub epsilon is the min
okay and okay so this local it's not
local it's it's not a new thing in our
work so this is this is the same thing
that uh charlie smart used in his in his
work
which by the way this was basically i
think only in his thesis i couldn't we
couldn't find anywhere where he had
published this result so i think it
ended up only in his in his uh
thesis dissertation uh somehow
so the what's really amazing here
is that the continuum guy here if i take
this min over balls
then minus uh non-local
laplacian of u epsilon
is bigger than zero it's exactly bigger
than zero okay so i can take the
solution of the local equation
and i can plug it into the non-local
equation and get exact
satisfaction here this is something you
see you you never see in these sort of
non-local to local problems there's
always like a taylor expansion going
from here to here and you have taylor
expansion errors
and so it's quite miraculous that you
can do this without any errors here and
this is
completely fundamental to getting
getting the rate in these problems so
once you have these two things
then you apply the comparison principle
for the non-local equation to relate you
epsilon to um
and that's where the rate comes from
so if you apply the comparison principle
or
the non-local equation
this gives
that so this is a subsolution property
super solution property so you get u n
epsilon minus u
epsilon so there's a couple of tricks
you have to play here so you get a cube
root because of them
so you get this
so essentially this is not a sub
solution relative to that because this
thing is positive that's zero you have
to make a perturbation trick you have to
take this super solution perturb it to
be a strict super solution so it's
larger than this right hand side that
perturbation trick is
is very non-trivial for the infinity
laplacian um and the ideas are contained
in uh smart's work and when you do this
perturbation trick you lose a little bit
and so you get this cube root of this
difference here
now of course you can remove the
epsilons everything is lipschitz so you
can remove the epsilons
and what you pay is just
an epsilon
cost here
um and then you optimize over epsilon
and that gives you
these results in these different
parameter regimes
and so let me say
you know i
i want to say a bunch of stuff but i
don't know how much time i have okay
yeah sure
yeah so this this uses actually the well
amle but really it uses this comparison
with cones that i'll talk a little bit
about yeah
yeah and that's that's crucially used in
in
this argument and this one as well yeah
yep
yeah it's it's it's used to get the
discretion on local
in the graph setting it's used for
locals non-local in the continuum set
use both these ideas
yeah
so because i only have a little bit of
time let me just it's like three lines
just to show how you get this local to
non-local let me show you how this works
and then the graph setting is a similar
thing but you replace everything with
graph analogs essentially
so
the proof of this call it star
okay so the first thing is i claim
that
u of y
bigger than u of x
plus
uh u of x minus u 2 epsilon
x over 2 epsilon
and i claim this is true for y
in the two epsilon ball
around
x okay so i have to wave my hands a
little bit to get this
and there's of course this is minus here
sorry
um so
the way this works is that you use this
thing called comparison with cones
which is actually quite simple so the
observation is that the infinity
laplacian of
of the cone function
is zero
for y is not equal to x so cones are
actually infinity harmonic
why is that true it's very simple it's
just
a cone
in the direction of the gradient it's
linear so its second derivative vanishes
right
the infinity
laplacian is just the second derivative
in the direction of the gradient okay so
cone functions are infinity harmonic
and so i can apply the comparison
principle between my infinity harmonic
function and this cone function and to
prove this all i need is that this
inequality holds on the boundary of the
ball and then it has to hold inside two
by the comparison principle on the
boundary of the ball the x minus y and
the two epsilon cancel and the u x's
cancel and i get exactly u y is bigger
than u two epsilon that's the minimum
over the ball okay so it holds in the
boundary the other part of the boundary
is the center of the ball because i'm
not infinity harmonic there at the
center of the ball where x is equal to y
that term is gone and y is equal to x
that's trivial as well okay so it holds
in the boundary it holds inside by the
comparison principle this is a
relatively smooth function you can prove
this comparison with cones without any
complicated viscosity solution machinery
it's almost like by hand you can you can
prove this
i i lied a little bit because we have to
use in place of cones we have to use
geodesic distances
on the domain because we have this
neumann problem okay but i'm going to
wave my hands around that stuff
now i simply minimize
over the ball of radius epsilon on both
sides
okay
minimize over this ball and
this this will be
um in the worst case epsilon so i got a
one over two
okay
um and in the end you get
u epsilon which is the min over the over
that ball
is bigger than a half uh u plus
u2 epsilon so you get this
just by minimizing this over the epsilon
ball
and now i write down the infinity
laplacian
of u epsilon
okay at x
remember this is the max plus the min
over the ball
and it's u sub epsilon and minus two u
sub epsilon of x
now essentially okay it's just one line
here so when you take the max over the
ball of the min over the ball
it's less than you you could prove okay
when you take the min
over the ball of the min over the ball
you get them in over the two epsilon
ball
then you get minus two epsilon
and that's less than zero by this right
here
okay
that's it
so it's this comparison with cones that
that that gives you this
local to non-local in almost no work and
this was this was this is not new to us
just to be clear so this is all
you know in a paper by smart and
armstrong
based on
charlie smart's thesis paper
so our
uh our contributions here are really in
the discrete to non-local so it's the
same comparison with cohen's argument
but
just to say in words
you have to
write down what's the right notion of
these cone functions
on the graph okay so there are solutions
of iconal equations on the graph you
have to show that they're infinity
harmonic on the graph they're actually
not they're sub-harmonic but that's fine
for the argument i only need one
direction here
and so you can prove comparison against
discrete cones for this guy and then the
proof reduces to convergence of the cone
functions in the graph these are first
order equations like carnal equations on
graphs and it's it's you know much more
straightforward to prove convergence of
these distance functions or cones on
graphs than it is to prove convergence
of the infinity harmonic functions on
graphs
and this makes a lot of sense because
you're looking at lipschitz extensions
and the cones are the the iconal
equations on graphs they describe the
metric on the graph and if the metric is
converging you should have convergence
of the absolutely minimal lipschitz
extensions as well
so i
um i will stop the proof there but i'll
just say a couple of things
about
extensions of this idea
so
really what we'd like to do actually
this is where i started with this
project and i wasn't able to to solve
this problem so we tackled this one
instead um what i'd like to do is look
at spectral convergence which i've
written some papers on recently
so this is if i have an ordinary graph
laplacian
and i have the uh i have an eigenvector
eigenvalue for this and i want to have
convergence to
a continuum eigenvector eigenvalue
problem
um there's a lot of papers recently on
convergence results in this setting
um
there's recently a paper by
um
myself and nicholas garcia trilos and
marta leviska
where we showed l infinity
convergence rates
um of order h in this setting
um but there's a length scale
restriction like i told you before so
this is
delta n to the d over d plus four
where delta n is not the exact same
thing i wrote before but it plays a
similar role so it has the same scaling
essentially
and you'd want to prove these
convergence rates all the way down to
the graph connectivity
threshold there is quite a bit knowing
down to that threshold but the rates are
not strong uniform rates so you can use
the gamma convergence framework of uh
dan slepchev and nicolas trilos to
push these convergence rates down to a
graph connectivity threshold but you get
worse rates that are in the l2 sense and
not in the l infinity sense and so if
you want these improved rates you need
some way to get
you know convergence of the operators
down to this length scale
and
to say a word about how you can do this
i think it's the same idea i talked
about passing to
a non-local operator on a homogenized
length scale okay
and what you can do let me just write
the formula here
um
is that
if i take a random walk
on the graph
um
maybe this isn't the best place to write
things
right over here
okay
so take a random walk on the graph i
won't write down the transition
probabilities as the usual one
defined by the weights in the graph
then if i have an eigenvector problem
here if this is the random walk graph
laplacian then i can write u of x
as the expectation
of
u of x k along the random walk 1 minus
lambda
minus k given that i start
the walk at x
and i would call this a fine and kak
formula cats
um and you can you know you should have
small eigenvalues large k
you can tailor expand this kind of thing
1 plus lambda k
like this we'll say x to denote that i'm
going to start at x
and so what you get is
i would call this
a homogenized eigenvalue problem lk of u
is equal to
lambda k
expectation
of u and so of course this expectation
is over the random walker not over the
random graph that we're constructing so
on so this
operator lk of u is the difference
between u and expectation of u over the
random walk
okay
it's uh laplacian because it's it's a
difference between you and it's average
locally okay this is what how you should
think of a
of a of a laplacian and the length scale
right should be
this is the role of um
epsilon from our our work
this should look somewhat like the sort
of
the set on which or the diameter of the
set on which the sort of bulk of the
heat kernel is concentrated which is
which is square root of k times
h so you get this larger homogenized
length scale
and then over here
this condition should become something
like
square root k h it's bigger than this
so if you take k large enough you can
get by with small much smaller values of
h we think
but this all boils down to
getting a consistency estimate for this
homogenized graph laplacian operator if
you want to know that this thing is
consistent with your
differential operator in the continuum
i think this is a hard problem at
smalling scales as far as i've seen so
far okay so understands it would require
having very very detailed knowledge of
the heat kernel on a graph at these very
small length scales where this is this
is hard to um obtain it i think it's
maybe similar to
some kinds of uh supercritical
percolation problems and so on but this
is essentially
the kind of things that i'm thinking
about
at the moment
and i think i will i will stop here and
happy to answer questions
[Applause]
so any questions more questions or
comments
all right so if we uh thanks for a
wonderful talk
ah okay now it's on so uh
on the right board you had those rates
right in these two regimes when h is
small and h is big and if i did quickly
right kind of the
it seemed to me that the best thing that
you can get is the connectivity length
scale to the power one over nine
as your optimal rate on the right hand
side right so
uh what is that you expect i would guess
linear right uh in the connectivity
scale yeah well right
for what is the best rate that you
expect in general over the right side is
there any reason to think that it's
going to be less than linear right less
than first order right
yeah so i i don't have any reason to
believe that what we've done is optimal
in any sense yeah no no yeah right yeah
um
you know
we we haven't done enough experiments to
sort of check this yet and it seems a
little difficult
i think essentially
you know we do think that this
that this condition
you know where right over here that h is
much bigger than um the graph
conductivity threshold we do think this
is essentially necessary so i don't
think you're going to get convergence at
smaller length scales like you do in
some gamma convergence problems and the
reason is that you can you know your
metrics not going to converge
if you say have a grid and you're forced
to go along a staircase
uh path between two points you're gonna
have a square root two factor difference
in lengths and so on so you do need this
kind of condition right so you're you're
not gonna get delta n
all the way down to graph connectivity
let's say
but i i would expect to get much better
than delta to the one over nine
um i i don't have any intuition about
what what it should be well although
yeah so so just make a comment i believe
that if you even if you go down below
right yeah you would probably uh you
know kind of there are these results on
homogenization of the lengths and it
would probably show that what you're
getting is a constant multiple right
there is a homogenization of the right
and uh you'll probably still be able to
relate the solutions up to some constant
uh factor right
uh okay that's another problem right
yeah thanks we can
we can talk yeah
good answer right there
okay perfect um very interesting talk uh
really like the the intuition would be
behind the proofs
um
i'm just curious about this this trick
you were talking about like meeting uh
halfway in the non-local setting
um
aside the specific rates of convergence
do you think something like this can
also be done for b
not only for the infinite laplacian ah
this is a good question so
i
it's much harder actually for the
laplacian
as far as i know i mean so people study
these non-local
equations right so this non-local
equation which is also one for the p
laplacian not the usual variational
peloplastine but this thing called the
game theoretical deposition the
non-local equations are studied by
probabilist and and pde people because
they have uh stochastic tug-of-war game
interpretations which can be done on
graphs or in a non-local domain
and in that
community as far as i know it's an open
problem to get a convergence rate for
the p laplacian p is not two or infinity
to get a convergence rate from non-local
to local
this is an open problem because
essentially you have sort of no business
getting rates anyways because the
solutions are not smooth so you don't
have smooth solutions
you know it's somehow miraculous that
you get a rate for the infinity
laplacian right right of course the uh
the u and epsilon i guess it should be
some sort of i don't know
uh convolution type of things in in in
the non-infinite regime right i guess uh
the right is these choices
really yes yes like tailored to to the
infield version right this this is
absolutely tailored to the infinity
laplacian i don't think you would use
the same thing for the piloplasty for
example right
yeah thank you yeah i would think
something like you know this this is
what's done in like the gamma
convergence is it some kind of
modification on some very small length
scale right and you know maybe the same
thing would work for the piloplasty and
i mean i'm sure it would i think i think
probably in diane's paper with matt
thorpe and so on they used a similar
convolution for the piloplasty
um but in terms of the convergence rate
then you know so i mean going from
discrete non-local might not be so
challenging but it's more like the going
from from local to non-local
right which you would normally need
regularity for that going local to
non-local you would tailor expand and
use regularity to get this um and in the
peloplastian or infinitoplasty you don't
have that regular you need like c2 alpha
or something you don't you don't have
this
and there's this like miraculous
comparison with cohen's thing that gives
it to you for infinity laplacian
well i mean there are like the you know
the cones look like uh like they're
fundamental solutions for the for the
laplacian
um so they look like
x to the
p minus d over p minus one i believe if
p of p is bigger than d so these older
cones but as far as i know it doesn't
characterize
solutions of the piloplasty and these
actually characterize so if your
function satisfies comparison with all
cones on all subsets of the domain it's
it's a
unique way to characterize the um
solution of the continuum problem or the
amle
and that's as far as i know specific to
the infinity lobby
[Laughter]
i just i want to make a small comment
regarding diane's question on how sharp
the rates are
i mean there's one way to improve the
rate a little bit namely by assuming
that the solution has positive gradients
everywhere this is a trick which is also
done in smart thesis and this basically
shows that our rates are really worst
case rates because if there's one single
point in the domain where the gradient
is zero then you we will have this
deterioration of the rates so you can
play with that in order to improve them
and then there's another thing namely um
we extend our graph solutions to the
continuum domain and then show rates for
this extension this gives us this
additional term of epsilon and we sort
of suspect that if you were just
interested in rates on the graph
um then you might actually be doing much
much better
now but this is sort of then a different
technique than what we did
yeah yeah very good points
the uh that's it's that cube root thing
that i talked about right
this doesn't show up if you if your
gradient never vanishes your solution
then you can you can get rid of the cube
root okay and it's somehow like when you
make the perturbation from
from sub solution to strict sub solution
you need a non-vanishing gradient for
this and there's an extra perturbation
trick to get to that non-vanishing
gradient essentially
okay other comments
questions
so if not let's think again jeff in all
these speakers of today